space just one of the many frontiers
explored by a Sid Meier game designer
guy who's sitting to the right of me on
the couch and lead designer on starships
coming out next week I said hello
excited to have you here excited to play
through some starships give folks an
idea for another way to play another way
to go through this world and choose your
affinity and lead your fleet to victory
exactly alright well let's get to it
let's start up and folks who there's
connections here between civilization
beyond Earth and one of the places
they're very apparent is when you start
a new game and make some choices exactly
the story that from beyond Earth
actually was part of the inspiration for
this game that idea of humanity leaving
having to leave the earth and to travel
to all these different places in the
galaxy mm-hmm start over kind of create
a whole new civilization there colonize
that planet and get to the point where
they've developed all this really cool
technology and can now travel from
system to system and that's where the
beyond Earth story ends and that's
really where this story picks up in the
trailer for this you'll kind of see how
we suddenly receive a message from
another remnant of humanity that that's
very exciting because we didn't know
what happened to all these people and we
find out that there are other people out
there they're still alive and then we
find out that there's trouble out there
there's trouble in the galaxy so you go
looking for trouble so we go looking for
trouble with our very cool starships and
this is the first screen where you kind
of pick the parameters of your game the
affinities from beyond Earth are one of
the first choices that you'll make each
affinity has a specific advantage kind
of can guide your play style supremacy
they get to start with one cool wonder
at convenient again which is a neat
advantage harmony they're able to repair
their starships at a lower cost because
they're in touch with the
organic nature of the galaxy purity kind
of represents humanist keeping humanity
human and so for helping out other
humans they get double the rewards that
the other female completing missions I
sit if you were gonna dress up for
Halloween as a particular affinity which
one do you think you would go for I I
think probably supremacy you know some
aluminum foil I think it'd be easiest to
kind of make a costume you know
something shiny and maybe some color
contacts exactly you're all good but in
terms of starting what kind of what do
you what have you been drawn to lately
the extra wonder the extra repair time
does a sort of depend on how you think
you're gonna be playing through I think
if I'm playing at the easier levels i
might choose supremacy because that
generally gives me a starting point it
might get something that improves my
torpedoes i'm going to make starships
based around torpedoes or something that
improves mike fighters but today i think
we'll try a little harder difficulty
level yes and for that harmony is very
handy because I I know I'm going to take
some damage so being able to repair that
at half the cost is going to be an
advantage great and then so some choices
that are familiar to any examines of civ
we've got the map size the difficulty
opponents and sort of victory conditions
right but it's something that's a little
different you actually have a choice of
leader within the affinity right these
are familiar from beyond Earth each of
them kind of has a personality kavitha
is a humanist mm-hmm LED kind of a
charismatic bulevar here's our
militaristic guy sir he looks for a
politician I think today will will go
with science again this kind of gives me
an idea what direction I want to push
based on these two free technologies
that I'm going to get it
in the game you sort of chart your
course right from those two Joyce's
right because I've already got a leg up
in a couple of directions once when I
choose such a way here all right to go
the medium map hard difficulty and I
think we're ready to go here excellence
this is a kind of just an overview of
how to play we'll be talking about some
of these ideas as we go through mm-hmm
here we are on sculpt taurus 4747 this
is our home planet this is where we just
played an awesome game of beyond Earth
and we can talk a second about the
connections between the two games there
are separate games you can play beyond
Earth and you know to play starships you
can play starships and not play beyond
Earth yeah but if you if you have both
games there's some kind of interesting
connectivity between the two games if
you're playing it beyond Earth game and
then you boot up starships you'll
actually see an extra option in that
first selection screen or you can
continue the beyond Earth game that
you're playing in starships and whatever
leaders are in your beyond Earth game
for example those leaders will appear in
starships ok whatever alliances or wars
are going on and be on earth those
alliances and Wars will carry over to to
be on dirt also not forgiving when you
take to the stars on exactly exactly so
if you want to kind of have that total
experience that's available if you play
it very clean boot is there any sort of
connection between your tech or you know
what you're sort of at any advance any
like sort of material advantages and the
affinities that the players have
expressed in beyond Earth will also
carry over to to starships so if you
were kind of pushing in a in a priority
direction in beyond Earth your affinity
will be purity and the same thing for
the other leaders ok in the game there's
some other connections but we're kind of
leaving those for the player to the
players to discover over time all right
and then you're whoever your leader is
we automatically be assigned their bonus
yes although you can change the your
leader when you go into starship you
actually can change any of the
parameters but you have the option to
start with that kind of beyond Earth
situation that mean that you've had all
right sculpt torus is producing
thousands of small icons for us
it looks like energy production science
and food exactly energy is what we use
to build our starships very important
metals we can build improvements to
planets and wonders science gives us
cool advanced technology and food allows
us to build more cities for more
population so sculpt tourists this is
kind of where we just played our our
beyond Earth game we now see that there
are there there are other planets out
there we're getting these communications
from these other planets finally and at
each planet there's a mission available
to us could be dark star here and the
reward for that mission if we accomplish
it is one free tech at this point at
this planet they're two cities on this
planet we can tell because of the
volcanic nature produces extra energy
and there's a special ability at each
planet this one will build wonders more
cheaply than any other planet so our
first decision is kind of what mission
where do we want to travel to which of
these planets do we want to help out but
first I'm going to do though is check
what my free what free technologies have
I gotten ok so it's made a sort of
random roll railways for you exactly so
I see that my lasers have been improved
and my torpedoes have been approved so
that might give me an idea of how to
power house already that's right let's
go erotic this galaxy and now so you I
you can once you let's I mean there's a
lot of free tech out there on those
missions if we were to do that we then
would get the choice of which that we
wanted to exactly and into exactly so we
have some energy we might as well
upgrade our starships here we notice
again that we have a level one laser
technology so why don't we bump those up
so what we're going to do lasers are
long-range weapons so and torpedoes are
also kind of long-range weapons so
perhaps our Theory here is going to be
to kind of build some starships that can
kind of hang back and and shoot at long
range mm-hmm there'd be many other
options we might go with cannon for
example which are short range weapons
are going to build some could build some
tank oriented
starships I noticed we already have also
have a stealth module here so we might
want to build kind of sneaky torpedo
launching starships more almost like
submarines so there's all sorts of
options as you kind of combine these
different components that are involved
in building your starships it's one of
the first kind of fun decisions that you
get to make yeah the choices you make
here in terms of upgrading your
different abilities really shapes your
battle tactics way back or at least it
should anyone is it you know probably
succeed on hard difficulty you're really
gonna have to lean into your strengths
or imagine so we're going to think in
terms of a starship that kind of hangs
back and one thing is going to be handy
is launching fighters here because they
can kind of go in to attack the enemy
while we're hanging back stealth is
probably something we might want to
consider a little little later on so you
just sold that still I just so off
exactly I I can have a almost infinite
customizability here in terms of
creating these starships with all these
different modules and all the modules
can be bumped up to higher and higher
levels as we get more and more energy
but your SP is in the red my SP is in
the red my speed is a bit low so let's
add some engines here to our starships
and you can see kind of as I add the
engine or take it off you can see the
engine module at the end of that harmony
ship changing Oni to reflect the more
powerful engines that I'm putting on
this on this starship and now my my
speed is up to five everyone knows point
seer things are more powerful exactly so
now you've got your fleet it's two ships
and when you're this in this view the
sort of Matthew you're really just
controlling you're using it to get
information about where to send your
fleet right what's the next mission that
we're going to return to go on so what's
the next mission Sid who that's that's
an interesting decision to coin a phrase
we cooked it the green missions are
easier and the orange missions are a
little more difficult but the rewards of
course are are greater and even though
none of these planets currently is in
the domain of another civilization it
doesn't mean that two turns from now
they won't be
exactly where we're going to run into
other civilizations fairly quickly and
they're also trying to expand their
Federation's their empires so it a is a
is a game about completing missions but
then it evolves to more of a higher
level competition with these other
civilizations and I think we'll kind of
see that as the game progresses oh this
is a cool planet hmm here I can increase
my population using less food on this
burden planet I think I'm going to take
a green mission to start with just so I
don't embarrass myself so I totally hear
this death craft alpha I'll get 200 more
energy that allow me to kind upgrade my
starship i'll just go to the easy one
just read it's only does grep alpha or
does have beta or gamma i might be a
little more difficult so here's our
tough here's our death craft island
Marauders have fielded a dreadknot a
powerful singles ship so the Marauders
are kind of the global bad guys in this
world they're there they're making
difficulty for us the barbarians are the
aliens they're the AI antagonist exactly
they're just plain bad in fact there's a
home planet which is a pretty awesome
planet it's really kind of cool boss
about that you get to a little bit later
in the game so tell us about so we
travel to this planet here's our the
bridge of our starship our crew here is
here to help us out one thing they can
do is kind of tell us tell us about the
enemy ship and again the enemy ships are
built out of those same modules that
we've used to build our ships so as we
become more and more familiar with them
we can kind of look there and say oh
he's got level two lasers got some
stealth hmm no fighters to speak of
exactly pretty fast pretty fast got a
torpedo level two shields and armor so
it's going to be an interesting battle
the computer is telling us that we have
a fifty three percent chance of
completing the mission alright thank you
computer appreciated that very inspiring
we want to know more about this planet
each each planet has something kind of
unique that going to affect the battle
in this case the asteroid fields in this
planet are going to
actually from turn to turn so that that
kind of adds another random element to
the to the battles hmm now if we wanted
to we could actually now that we kind of
know the mission and know what what's
unique about the planet we could
actually reconfigure our starships if we
wanted to but I think we've designed
some pretty cool starship so we'll we'll
take them into this battle any good
advice here torpedoes are vital maximum
damage is okay Peter got some torpedoes
and we've got to kill the giant eyeball
dread not exactly all right we're gonna
go into battle here I just quite have
been bigger and there are two of them he
actually went through a wormhole there
okay that's not that was the same one
that was the same one yes so we have
these you could pursue into the wormhole
but you also you got your lasers you got
your torpedoes may be a longer range
battle is better for you yes so we're
going to head over to the other side of
the map where the Death Star has I'm
sorry the dark beer dreadnought has has
hopped and down here we kind of have the
actions and we can taking and each of
our turns we can take one particular
action right now the the enemy is not in
range so we don't have a firing action
as well take the opportunity then to
launch our fighters if your fighters in
play right oh look at those cute little
guys
those were the laser yeah he has two
lasers on his death star there so took a
little bit of damage to check out our
fighters here they have some cool cannon
on them just kind of let them know that
we're here fighters are replenished on
each mission so they're a little bit of
little disposable some degree you have
to be super cautious with them as you
might with your core fleet ships so
we're gonna can't get real close cannon
are only really good at close range so
I'm going to hope to get him next turn
for this chair i'm going to lurk here
behind these asteroids these asteroids
will block is his lasers so that's a
good place to kind of hang out hmm also
kind of blocking your lasers yes that's
that's like it would get a shot at them
from over here I'm gonna again lurk a
little bit here and wait for a better
shot on the next turn
similarly here so we're kind of kind of
surround him a little bit because if we
can get a shot from behind or at the
flank it's gonna be a lot more effective
than painting he's shield hit on yeah
okay that was quick shot ouch right next
to the end turn button there those to
arrows and it you know sort of ending
your turn facing the enemy can that's
where your shields are more focused
towards the front of your ships exact
because it can be a good strategic move
to minimize the damage you're going to
take if you know you're going to take a
hit exactly and I can actually get my
fighters around behind this where his
shields are weaker do a fair amount of
damage oh it shields are down okay this
is good this is good okay feeling sure
yeah as we check him out now we notice
his shields which were level 2 before
are now down to level 1 because they are
we achieved a critical hit mm-hmm on
your shield so this is good on the SS
malediction al addiction who that sounds
better oh I'm gonna be able to get this
fighter behind him okay oh that's a lot
always don't know oh okay the Jolly
Roger then the Royal Blues way to go
guys so our strategy of kind of hanging
back with our starships and sending
those fighters into seemed to pay off in
this particular ticular mission why
would you ever fight with your main
starships when your fighters are so
effective exactly that's that's our
strategy kind of in this game now part
of that was the fact that we got those
two technologies at the beginning mhm so
we're we get a reward we were promised
some energy here and we're going to get
that the other thing that we get is
influenced that's kind of what you're
going for one of the ways to win this
game is to have fifty percent of the
galaxy's population kind of under your
control part of your Federation and the
way to get them the joinder Federation
is to impress them with how cool you are
and how much you can help them out and
we've done that to the level of two out
of four influence on this particular
planet so doing a mission for a planet
the first civilization to sort of show
up and help them out those are those
will give you some boat some influence
exactly there's what we get one
influence for doing a green mission an
easy mission and one influence because
we're the first people first humans to
visit this this planet so that gives us
to influence which establishes a trade
route which means we get half of the
resources that are being produced at
this at this planet this planet is the
knowledge planet so they're actually
getting twice as much science as a
typical planet nice that's very cool now
we do notice a little red down here we
did take a little damage to our
starships fortunately as the fortunate
we just got 200 energy yeah that's got
more than covering your repair costs and
where the Harmony so our repair costs
are a little lower hmmm and so now you
have a chance you can even though your
fleet is sort of not at your home planet
you're not heading into combat you can
still use this time to write out to kid
out your ships customizing designing
your stars which is kind of one of the
core core features of the game and you
can really do that at any time I noticed
we didn't have any torpedoes here so
let's start torpedoes are ya take
advantage of that extra torpedo tech yes
hmm well that mission was fun but that
was an easy mission why don't we try
darkstar little stars are ya little
harder mission here see how that goes
forth
Sydney 62 they're using cloaked fighters
in this mission yeah I see some glowing
hexagonal outline is twisting okay now
there's a really cool variety of
missions I think that's one of the
things we really tried to push in this
game is to make each mission feel
different so there was that their dread
not that we tackled on the last mission
here they're using cloak fighters their
missions where you try to have to try
and escape it's not really about
attacking the enemy escorting colony
ships or transport let's see what we're
up against success 14 del fighter and a
fighter squadron now they are they have
the cloaking ability so we're gonna need
some sensors here we got to decide what
system we're going to give up to put
sensors on our ship here is you can't
very well go into a tougher mission
against cloaked enemies without having
at least one ship able to spot them
exactly exactly maybe I don't know
what's gonna be the fighters really work
well for us I think torpedoes who just
bought these but I think they're going
to have to go we're gonna need centers
in this mission to uncover those club
now did you take a little bit of an
energy loss for buying it and selling
yeah there's a little friction there
that they can't get quite as much back
as you did as you paid for them but
now you've got sensors on one ship which
sort of does that just kind of send out
a ping and yogurt and radius like a rate
it's like a sonar it kind of goes out
and if you goes out far enough to where
they are it will reveal where they are
and happily the starship the star system
contains an especially low concentration
of ionized particles which will increase
the range of sensors and weapons
excellent all right let's go pick out
those stealth fighters if your fighter
squadron del Sol a purple radius is kind
of like how close our ship has to get to
actually see them and that's including
your sensors no our sensors are more
powerful than that so we're gonna pull
up here that's the way you would be able
to see them just normally with yes we
have no sense if we travel that close to
them they would suddenly appear probably
that would be a bad thing you'd be a
little close for comfort exact and game
is not too strong or of a laser kind of
ship so let's see if art for close
enough to
and so that was your sort of one in
addition to your move that was your
action that was my action for that term
yes so I'm going to launch those sandy
fighters here now this is we call a
narrow passage it's so it's we can move
through that those asteroids on this
turn but on a different other turn the
next turn they might be open or might be
closed so the the kind of the
battlefield evolves and changes turn
deterrent it's an interesting part of
the strategy the flanking route that was
available to you might shut down or you
might get exposed to one depending on
how the afterwards good well there were
some screams in space people can hear
you scream over and he cloaked himself
again so i am going to kind of hide my
guys behind this planet here hope they
get close enough to i can blast them on
the next term
this was an orange miss you full on lose
your ownership oh yeah oh man it's all
bad as all y'all so no man and orange
mission no joke all right stick with
green missions yeah seriously that was
really quick okay uh so that what could
you have done in that case you know if
your ships were outfitted differently if
you had more shields I probably should
have gone with level two sensors because
I the distance that those sensors were
able to reach was just not far enough to
reveal where the enemy was so you could
get a long-range shot off and probably
would you have taken them out that
quickly with that long with your like
one salvo because they're kind of small
and Fighter II i probably would have
used my sensors to reveal them and then
send my fighters in to to take them out
but they were they were pretty powerful
like I have to admit they did a good job
way to go AI good work yeah I mean I
guess you know you're playing the game
on hard and you're taking on a tough
mission you should shouldn't be a walk
in the park now the other thing that's
happening here is our crew is starting
to become a little tired yeah what are
the consequences for that loss I mean
obviously your ships are in bad shape
now right I've got a cost of repairing
them right and every mission that I take
on two of my crew go from this green
state with these incredibly powerful
brain waves oh yeah to the red state
with the flatline brain waves and so
they basically that affects all of my
systems my laser sound quite as powerful
my shields aren't quite as good and its
really a risk/reward an interesting
risk/reward decision how far do you push
this voyage before you decide to give
your crew the shore leave a wonderful
surely now we're we're down we're down
cruise down pretty low here and we need
to repair our starships so this is going
to be an opportunity maybe to go and
shore-leave
and one thing to kind of consider is
that whatever planet use you take your
shore leave on you actually get one more
influence on that planet because your
crews very well behaved and spends a lot
of cash and so people enjoy you in the
local economy with all these low
brainwave soldiers stumbling around just
buying stuff just getting their brain
waves back now but shortleaf also is
sort of like a like a turn it cycles and
then it'll you gain all of your resource
production exactly right that's when you
get all your resources your crew comes
back to full health the only problem is
that all the other sibs in the game get
to take their turn as well and do the
same thing that you were doing they get
to take on missions they get to gain
influence on planets they get to
generate their resources so the more you
can do on your turn the better but as
you can see pushing it too far can have
some concept now before you do it though
do you have you have resources of other
types I mean you've spent energy for
your ships but you have food you have
what are the gears called in this one
metal production metal yes yes like
there's planetary improvements you can
do would it behoove you to do like boost
your output before taking the show yeah
that's actually a great idea I know that
I'm going to get an influence here which
is going to mean I get all the resources
from this planet this planet is actually
really good at generating science mm-hmm
so I'm going to build an improvement
here that will actually accelerate that
the crypto lab is going to add fifty
percent to the science production on
this planet I still like that the
production of resources is directly
proportional to the population of the
planet so I'm going to add another city
here to also increase my production
that's gone up to 450 mm excellence and
let me don't have enough energy to
repair these guys knew or cleaned out
and doomed here so we're gonna have to
rest and get them cumulate those
resources for our next next voyage
they're happy Julie they're enjoying
themselves oh look he's good coming into
town ok those other groups out there
trying to take over this galaxy as well
so we've enjoyed our stay or leave can
we get one more influence and we now
emulate all of the resources at this
point so we're now getting 900 science
which is very cool that's a lot of
science that's a lot of cool science
there's some of those early science
upgrades like 50 or they were find out
well we can take a look yeah let's take
a look we can use our science to to
research now all these scientists
science they're they're actually
directly related to all the systems on
our ship so we're deciding which systems
do we want to kind of globally make more
more effective and more powerful hmm say
lasers again we ready level one of those
illusions on our ships and fighters we
like we like fighters that technology as
well know what's so what's a brandom
module mean for the fight that means
that normally fighters have one from one
engine one shield and one cannon and but
with level one of artificial
intelligence will get an extra module so
it could be an extra cannon could be
good to be a torpedo could probably not
a torpedo could be better better shields
so each fighter now we'll have a little
bit of a different
configuration when we launched them a
little bit better capabilities yeah all
right one extra system power of science
science is cool oh this has gone to read
now oh man oh let's not go over there
hmm a little shell-shocked down yeah
let's there's a green mission let's
travel over there and that also happens
to be the planet of the green
civilization we don't want them to this
is actually this is the planet generate
extra energy so that is definitely
planet that we want to we want to have
one of the things I talked about the
crew fatigue and whenever we travel from
one planet to another that generates one
level of crew fatigue so what we can do
to avoid that is build these high speed
warp connections between the planets and
what I'm going to do is build that here
work Nexus Nexus operational
and so now when I travel back to my home
planet there's no fatigue involved but
they travel more quickly and as my
Federation grows I can actually link it
together with a whole network of these
warp connections that allow me to travel
really quickly from one side of the
galaxy two to the other seem pretty
powerful there they are yeah they're
cool and the other advantage is that if
there's a special ability on them one of
the planets I don't have to actually go
there to take advantage of it if I have
a warped connection to it I can just
take advantage of it wherever I am in
the galaxy now the special ability to
mean is that sort of the produces more
energy or more science or yes this for
this planet for example i can add new
starships to my fleet for a lower cost
in the designers planet so if i had i
was either at that planet or connected
that planet by a warp connection i could
use that ability and that comes into
play as you expand your Federation a
little bit later that you kind of get to
take advantage of all these little
special abilities that the different
planets deciding which one's important
for you to have in all place and ring
ring or in all the connected places yes
all right let's check out huh bonus 98
alrighty
90 hmm let's so two of our starships
have been cornered by a marauder
squadron in an unfamiliar part of the
galaxy we need five turns before going
to warp our way out of here so this is
not about blowing up the enemy starships
this is about holding on for five turn a
very different kind of different kind of
mission we're going to unfamiliar part
of the of the galaxy and this is a
little fun thing very threw in there
your danger wash our GPS is ridiculous
you don't know how to get we need five
turns to figure out how to get out of
this part of the galaxy can't you get a
lot faster I'm trying captain so let's
see what the enemy is gonna look like in
this place so they've got a cruiser okay
um that is a mighty powerful ship three
lasers level five shields you totally
dogs sometime level five engines refuse
so all we need to do to win here is kind
of keep away for from these guys for
five terms so we're going to probably
use some of that energy that we
generated in the last surely to think in
terms of maybe stealth or speed those
are the two things that are going to
kind of keep those guys away so see how
much put level two stuff from these guys
so we're going to try the hiding
strategy instead of the running strategy
and shoot what you can't see all right
should check out what
oh okay so this is a cool a bit llamas
let turned out really well there's a
cool ability of this at this planet that
our stealth systems are automatically
activated so it doesn't take one of our
action points hmmm to turn on our
stealth system so that is perfect now
your stealth systems will apply to the
ships that they have equipped but when
you launch fighters today is there like
a stealth umbrella they can fall under
or are they just immediately know
they're they're exposed their powerful
bit fragile now the other thing I can do
since VAR a here the green the green
Empire already has an influence there we
can actually talk to their leader and
and basically what he has to say he says
you know we're already welcomed we
already have influence here will give
you 200 food if you'll just go away Oh
interesting so we're starting to have
the diplomatic relations with for this
ability with the different leaders
however you know they're right next to
your home planet right you give it up
that easily no no no no we are we are no
interest in your laughable proposal so
at performing a mission on a planet that
has influenced from another civ is kind
of like an act of aggression against
their they're not going to be real they
don't own that planet so they don't see
it as an act of war but it is going to
make them a little less friendly towards
us it's sort of stepping on their toes a
little right we're both kind of trying
to impress the people just planted to
convince them to become part of our of
our Federation so let us just go into
this mission
alright so there they are hmm heading
your way there stood they have some acne
analyst elders / they want some fighters
okay yeah we are going to how much room
do an oeuvre away but there's also that
wormhole right yeah maybe pop into that
we could I guess depends I can you know
for sure where you pop out though know
it's random but this one if we hang out
over here and as they get close jump in
there that's actually a good idea there
we're going to use our impulse power
since we didn't use our actions for
anything else we get one extra move this
term we're going to head for that
lots of fighters like us annoy them
leave them as the rear guard yeah
sacrifice will be remembered they're
also taking advantage that ability to
automatically have their stealth systems
engaged
but now going through that could dump
you at this top right one that is
actually closer to them right so I'm
going to wait till they get close now
they're not able to see your main ships
because of stealth but can I see the
fighters or is there sort of a visible
range is eating they can see the
fighters yes which actually might be
drawing then towards us so I'm going to
send my fighters off in a different
direction maybe they can lure them all
the time keeping track of the turn
counter yeah we have to hold out for
five turns all we need well they've
launched a torpedo at expiry okay so
it's more pedo is not like other weapons
in that suit because you basically you
know between lasers and cannons those
are going to fire depending on what
range you are you're not going to choose
to fire cannons you're just going to
fire from closer range because you know
your cannons will hit but a torpedo you
activate and you can fire and you can
sort of aim it into any place you want
it's not just an automatic sort of lock
on needs a lock on solution exactly you
aim it and you choose the moment to
detonate it and you can it'll actually
travel over a number of turns so if
there and it also will pass through
asteroids and things like that that your
normal weapons won't so if they're kind
of lurking or hiding behind some
asteroid you can kind of flush him out
with a with a torpedo torpedoes will
also destroy the asteroid again if you
need to get a kind of get through so
much a hole right so there's a kind of
cruises for torpedoes in it in the game
all right
I get their attention we're just gonna
hang out here they get a little closer
that's where pedo kind of changed course
a little bit is that a thing there's a
little bit of solar wind that kind of
way Oh No took out all right they did
their job yeah they put it that way
through them off to the side they're
using their sensors here to trans- but
it looked like you were pretty well out
of range that's and click and hold out
for one more turn here really get closer
enemy Corvette engines critical now does
that mean your movement yes our movement
is greatly reduced unfortunately
unfortunately all we just have to make
it to this in turn up Kate here oh nice
and now once you're through there no
they're gonna have a much even if they
come out of the gate you have a chance
for a sort of okay get out sloop get
into your stealth around here think I
can do this one more time so we have to
hold out
and now they're coming back are there
any negative consequences for going
through the wormhole can you like end up
taking damage or no not coming out the
other side that's space is weird no no
they're not it's just that you don't
know where you're going to pop out and
it takes one of your movement points to
do that okay although there is a wonder
that you can build that actually allows
you to control when you do and don't
pass through the those jump gates but
that's ended well speaking of wonders
can we actually take a look at those
real questions we we sent out a
solicitation for questions on Twitter so
if you folks are following gamespot on
twitter you would have seen that and
some of the questions from our community
do revolve around wonders you know
mm-hmm how many are there and how can
their benefits be kind of shared among
your civilization there are 14 different
wonders and they the advantages that
they provide you apply across all of
your planet starships that they apply to
your civilization as a whole mm-hmm one
of the kind of cool elements of wonders
is that each planet can only build an
ace one specific type of wonder so at
our home planet here we can build the
JumpStart wonder what we found was that
people would players would kind of focus
in on their favorite wonder and always
build that same wonder mm-hmm but the
fact that each planet can only build a
specific type of wonder kind of makes
you try out different things jumpstart
is a cool wonder what it does it is
allows us to always have the first move
in in battles there are there are
wonders that I to launch your fighters
and they can then use their entire
movement allowance on their first turn
for example as supposed to just that one
just that one turn so you can just
launch them and send them immediately
towards the enemy and is there a way to
let's say Serpentis 58 can we tell what
wonder could be built there do we have
to have influence therefore we have to
actually include that into our
Federation before we can determine so
you don't know what one you're gonna be
able to build until it's fully within
the fold
gotcha there are wonders that allow your
torpedoes to be invisible which is very
cool there are wonders which allow your
crew to perform at full efficiency even
though they have read on their heads so
there's a whole bunch of wonders that
kind of again will kind of steer your
gameplay and maybe a little bit
different direction you know it with the
Wonder the naval tradition wonder which
allows your crew to be at full
efficiency you're probably going to push
your missions birther you're probably
going to you know perform three or four
or five missions on on a voyage because
you're not too concerned about how how
the redness of your of your crew and you
want to you know get as many gets much
influence as you can I guess what would
be the limiting factor than if it wasn't
your crew one search to your spaceship
or actually once all ten of your crew is
red you have to end your voyage at that
point oh you're gonna they're gonna
mutiny otherwise yeah we don't want that
weight is mutiny I can name you lee or
no then you just sort of you stop and
you stop the player short you're getting
to that point out when you can't
actually drive them to mutiny but
theoretically that's what would happen
okay so I see we see now with the green
homeworld stealth torpedo is that their
wonder than they've been so they have
that they have the wonder that allows
their computers to be invisible they can
launch them and we don't actually know
where they where they are which until
they explode so that's actually a very
very fun wonder for us to have not for
them to have not to go yes per se hmm so
what I'm gonna think I'd like to make
this planet part of our Federation we
need one more influence and we know that
by having shore leave there yeah we can
get that that one more influence so I'm
going to travel
and we noticed hair blades we did get
the one influence for performing the
green mission unfortunately we're we're
not the first to visit this planet so we
didn't get that extra bonus for for
being the first so we're still competing
over that planet with with Elodie there
all right well while you take your shore
leave and then maybe plan the next move
just a few more questions here before we
wrap up folks you're curious and I'm
curious about this one too is is there
going to be any kind of steam workshop
availability here because and the thing
that inspired me was a mission that I
took when I was playing a couple weeks
ago where I did have to do that kind of
escape oh and I had to escape through an
asteroid field it was kind of a maze and
it reminded me of an episode of
Battlestar Galactica where they're just
jumping and jumping and escaping and all
they have to do is stay ahead of the
enemy so foul nedu do a full Battlestar
mod take over starships you know let
that happen if you guys have any ideas
on that that's a great question that's
not something that we're supporting at
the moment but you know we're always
listening to the community always
interested in feedback and suggestions
so can't make any promises but that's a
very very neat idea I think there would
be some enthusiasm out there for that
already talking to talking to led here
she yeah she has called us up here and
introduced herself and she's a little
bit as the diplomatic aspect of the game
mmm kind of telling us she's got these
two starships in her sleep she's a
supremacy mmm has got three planets her
home planets and she has the influence
on to other planets this is that planet
that we were kind of contesting with her
oh she's got to plant influence we have
the one mhm we're interested to see what
she's been working on she's been
researching some technology we can kind
of get an insight into what is happening
with the other leaders in this
hmm alex t is being large enough for the
both of us she's not ready to make peace
with us yes there let's just stay out of
each other's way and everything will be
fine okay all right fine ok so again
she's gone to that planet and gotten
that third influence she cleverly
resting her starship there give us one
they can top that lamp got kavitha yeah
she's playing the purity I'm affinity
it's got a couple planets who kind of
arguing with Elodie there and green and
the orange fighting over that planet
mm-hmm they've been busy soon yeah
they've got a lot of influence and she's
actually got an alliance with with
Suzanne fielding so you get a sense of
the connections here between the
different civilizations that are out
there all right well before we wrap up
here let's just get a quick idea of what
the endgame here might look like what
are the give us quick rundown of the
bigger conditions and what which one at
this point you think you might target if
it's even early enough to that idea
where you go ok so we noticed this
planet now that we have that fourth
influence has become part of our
Federation one of the ways to win is to
have fifty percent of the of the
population of the galaxy in our
Federation yep right now we have nine
percent we've got a ways to go certainly
another way to win is to build seven of
those fourteen possible wonders if you
can get three of your technologies up to
the maximum level which is level six
that is also a victory condition okay
and the classic domination victory if
you can capture the homeworld of all the
other civilizations and out that are out
there that is another
victory cos stars will be yours we can
just take a quick look here we can see
kind of the diplomatic status of the
different leaders whose whose at war
with who who's friendly again be so are
you shouting it Elodie and way yeah
where we are not getting along very well
and we've been really kind of contesting
that one planet you know that has
contributed to do a little bit of bad
feeling so the your kind of asking how
the game evolved so so phase one is kind
of about accomplishing these missions
and getting influenced building your
Federation after a while we start to run
out of planets and everybody every
civilization is going to own one planet
or another and our borders start to bump
up against each other and then we
actually start to have missions that
involve action against the other
civilizations sleeps and we're
eventually gonna try and take out their
home world in which case they're all of
what they own becomes becomes ours and
hopefully that'll get us on the way to
oh it's 54 take over it doesn't just
leave them vacant and waiting for some
of the snow we're really looking for
that acceleration towards the end of the
game I think we want the game not to
kind of drag out but to kind of
accelerate to a conclusion and the
reason that's really the reason that we
have this mechanism where if you can
take out the enemy toon world which
they've defended with extra defenses and
things like that then you take over all
their planets and it gives you a real
bump 10 words boom your population is
swells exactly this case full on double
there also one other thing there are
there's a home world planet for the
Marauders and the Pirates that are kind
of like the bad guys out yeah you
mentioned that are single planet but
they're there they have a popular large
population so if you can kind of take
them out in the middle game they also
give you a really powerful bump towards
the end game high-value targets exactly
exactly alright sidwell starships is uh
coming out next week yes next Thursday
March 12 Thursday March twelfth y'all
can play starships on a couple different
platforms be available on the pc and mac
and also on your
pad excellent sid meier starships ladies
and gentlemen thanks for watching